[Music]
cancer sticks you know every single hot
dog shaves six years off your life and
it shrinks your ovaries I thought you're
a pro-choice
I just do not understand the concept of
cooking perfectly good vegetables in
carcinogens you might as well start
smoking again
don't you guys know that they inject
burger patties with antibiotics and
hormones before they even get to the
store the government probably adds in a
vaccine there so they can control us
don't you know that the best part of the
watermelon is the Rind totally
sugar-free and keto friendly
or Christy do you really need the carbs
here Nature's bun
[Music]
no no corn is just straight up sugary
GMO poisons and your body knows it
that's why it comes out the other end
undigested within an hour Nature's detox
[Music]
nice seeing you too oh my God I'm gonna
need a full cancer Detox After this
where are my charcoal pills oh